so
last night
was uh was interesting
it sort of hit the adventure was really
kicking off it was a great conversation
piece it all sounded interesting for me
and it's
it wasn't a reality at all
really and then it turned very real very
quick
come near the end of uh the train
journey in bernanke
and that's when it really really hit
because that at that moment that's when
i drop
english other than these diaries etowana
um
[Music]
something weird psychologically happened
inside me where like there was a little
bit of panic i have to say there's a
little bit of like oh [ __ ] going on
within me anna was there outside of the
train very nice woman
she took the bag she was charging she
was like a very like go-getter type of
woman
and all of a sudden i was like crossing
over streets getting into marsha
marshuka
and off the bus
and uh whisking off to
asupanka
through the countryside
which is beautiful like
just
canvases of
sunflowers
yellow
yellow fields blue skies
and golden teeth
and the old people
smiling at me it was
quite a combination i've never really
come across
and
eventually got out to this village
[Music]
[Music]
oh
met the family family is very cool
beautiful children three beautiful
children
i feel bad i have to say i feel bad in a
way i'm coming to them and i can't
really speak so much to them interesting
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
it was tough i was like tarzan swinging
from the ropes
like really in complete sentences
so the kids definitely broke that ice
for me which was helpful
[Music]
um
[Music]
francis
mexico
[Music]
yes
it's
you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this little village to the home to the
family did a little gardening we ate a
nice meal
and it's
first impressions there's just a ton of
innocence with it
and then
just walked around around and time
really just
slows down here
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm tired my head hurts
and uh
at this moment i'm a little bit
like oh [ __ ]
but it's gonna be cool i know it will be
cool
and i'm lucky with this family
that's that story
to be continued tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you